this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile America's best unlimited
network serious questions so if the
force is biological in nature does that
mean it exists in every species do you
even have to be sentient to use the
Force Luke didn't know he had it until
obi-wan told him so could an egg use the
force could a plant can dogs have be so
cute if dogs use the Force
I mean if so it goes without saying Air
Bud definitely has the force if Luke had
to kill Vader to become a Jedi
where all those younglings gonna have to
kill their dads too
and since Yoda pretty much tells Anakin
to break things off with Padme does
every Yuengling get the sex-talk from
Yoda do it
you must not and I know they can't get
married but Jedi rules are only
explicitly against attachment so could a
Jedi have a one-night stand I never do
things I miss and is there a more
phallic weapon than the lightsaber in
cinema history
no right why did Obi once sit down next
to Luke and Return of the Jedi do ghosts
get tired was he doing it for Luke to
feel more comfortable if so does it take
more concentration for a ghost to sit
convincingly on a log without his legs
disappearing or was out Guinness just a
tired old man
ghost fax who was going to buy those
ratha tars Han Solo captured up at that
dude was into some weird stuff
what exactly happened when Yoda sent
Luke into that cave on Dagobah was it a
vision did Yoda slipped something into
Luke's soup is it always Darth Vader in
that cave is the Vision Quest always
part of the Jedi training like did
obi-wan Kenobi have to fight Darth Maul
in a cave at some point and then did all
the makeup and tattoos and stuff run off
Darth Maul's face and reveal Obi Wan's
face underneath
regardless I think it's pretty clear
that Jedi visions are very on the nose
Joseph Campbell why does obi-wan hide
his identity as a Jedi Knight without
changing out of his Jedi robes I've been
in this fight since I was six years old
did the rebellion really hire a
six-year-old caste in Endor we see a
baby genius what's the rebellions policy
on child soldiers anyway did the Empire
make a viral video about Saagar era
that's like their version of kony2012
wedge antilles helped destroy two Death
Star's was he pissed Lando just showed
up after snitching on Luke and became a
general
he's a protocol trying to help
why did little Anakin think a protocol
droid could help his mom with hard labor
she's literally a slave she doesn't need
to translate anything if Darth Vader
doesn't have a back to take candy does
he just have to use lotion what poor
Imperial Guard has that job sorry about
your tk-421 why was Luke's plan to save
Han Solo from Jabba so complicated if
he's just gonna run in and chop everyone
to death anyway he even said Lando ahead
of him to get a security guard gig
how long was Lando working there who
were his references did he know Jabba
was gonna make r2d2 into a sand bar
waiter did he and our to practice the
diving board maneuver before they did it
in real life and if Luke planned all
this out so thoroughly how did he not
know about the giant trap door under his
feet why does Luke keep getting tricked
into falling into holes why is Dexter
jettster running a 50s nostalgia diner
on Coruscant is being a weapons expert
his sidekick or is running a 50s diner
his sidekick what is this place
nostalgic for anyway
was there a version of American 50s pop
culture in the Star Wars galaxy and if
so was our 1950s inspired by a previous
1950s brought to us by aliens
for instance that robot waitress has a
Bronx accent is that where the Bronx
accent comes from space and where do you
even get vinyl booths in the Star Wars
galaxy I bet they make them on Alderaan
this episode was brought to you by
t-mobile switch to America's best
unlimited network
you